let me pull up this story we have this
is a daily mail says sickening youtube
star couple is slammed for comparing
abortion to the holocaust and branding
it the world's most deadly killer in
pro-love documentary shared with 13
million followers cole and savannah
lebron have come under fire for
contrasting the amount of people who got
abortions to the amount who were killed
during the holocaust you know the first
thing i'm going to mention is
frame check yeah do do pro-life
conservatives
find this sickening and are they
slamming them or is this the instance of
pro-life personalities large followings
expressing their views and the left
opposing them calling this i think the
daily mail very obviously framed this in
a way that makes it appear like
everybody's mad about this but you know
you guys who are more conservative
pro-life i'm curious what you think
about this couple there's only one
reason to be pro-life and that is that
you believe
that uh well two
the two the two basic
assertions of the pro-life person is
that the child in the womb is a human
being and that it's never okay to
intentionally directly murder an
innocent human being and so if you
believe both of those things then you
you must agree that this holocaust
comparison
is valid because those are we've got 60
million abortions in in the united
states roe v wade are those human beings
are not if they're human beings that's
60 million humans a 60 million people
who are killed and we we've never seen
the systematic slaughter of 60 million
human people before anywhere on earth so
this is a
the 60 million number is this like what
what are the stats what are the stats
behind this like well what's interesting
about the what's interesting about in
the us abortion in the u.s is the
largest
single group of women who have abortions
are black women i think it's like 36
of abortions are
for um are done by black mothers and uh
and that doesn't count california i
believe and california has the most
abortions in the country and it doesn't
count california because california
doesn't keep data
on the race of women who whose children
are aborted
so what are i mean it does seem to me
that there is a genocide against black
babies in this country
my question is on the statistics about
60 million i think i think it's
important because
the data i saw says that the
overwhelming majority of abortions are
listed as no reason given
so i'm wondering you know of the 60
million abortions if we're going to say
it is slaughter
are some of these you know how would you
define them is it is this entire 60
million just you know abortion as
contraception are there you know medical
crises or interventions
the vast majority of cases that's that
like we were talking about the medical
we have to get into it again but there's
never actually a reason to abort a child
for for uh for medical reasons but this
is like we could even put all that aside
because that's like one percent of the
cases 99 of cases are essentially
abortion for contraception it's just you
you don't want the child because you
don't feel like having a kid or because
you don't think you can afford the child
so that is uh i i really you know re
real quick because i have i have a
philosophical ethical libertarian uh
question about this and i think i'd love
to hear your thoughts matt and it's that
uh
you know personally
i i have an issue with government
intervention in terms of a person being
required to provide their body to
another person and so the conundrum
arises with two individuals sharing one
body and then the state determining that
one person must provide that body to
another person typically the response i
get and i accept is um well if a woman
chooses to engage in you know
reproductive acts and then she brings
into her harbors life she's accepted a
responsibility in that regard but then
the question of rape arises if a woman
is forced to harbor another person then
the government intervenes and says we're
going to enforce that you will provide
your blood and your body to another
person that kind of freaks me out well
let me i'll respond in general terms
even
because what you're talking about that
principle is true that you shouldn't be
you know forced to provide your body to
another person and that would apply not
just to uh babies conceived through rape
but to all babies they're conceived
right so
right here's the response that's a
challenge um first of all
it turns out we as human beings are not
these autonomous uh free individuals who
have no responsibilities to anybody else
it's just that's just not the reality we
have responsibilities in society but
especially according to relationship so
that's my problem with when it's framed
that way of uh well you shouldn't be
forced to provide your body to somebody
yeah i shouldn't be forced to provide
like an organ to my neighbor but to my
child
like the relationship there
carries with it certain responsibilities
so what i would say is
should
let's let's let's take it outside of the
womb
should parents be forced quote unquote
to care for their babies or at least to
find someone else who will like should
it be legal for
a mother to say of her six-month-old
baby i don't really want this baby
anymore and to just like throw the child
in a dumpster or drown the child in a in
a bath or even just leave the child at
home and just go somewhere and leave we
would say no you can't do that because
yeah you you don't have a responsibility
to the six month old across the street
but that's your child you're the parent
there is a difference between something
that's directly connected to your
bloodstream and this is why i say i
understand and accept the argument that
if a person chooses to engage in an
action they have a responsibility but if
someone is forced into that position
i just find it creepy that you know a
woman can be victimized by someone then
have i understand the child is innocent
in this regard i absolutely believe that
when it comes to rape but then for just
a person to be told by the state
this the the being that harbor this
harbored in your body that is using your
blood and nutrients
that was put there by force you must
nurture and nourish here's the thing
about that right it's not
the law necessary so we have the laws we
have the state can tell you what you
know tells you what to do or whatever
but the real problem is that we have a
lack of a shared value system and if we
had values that encouraged motherhood
and that encouraged valuing life
regardless of what the law is we would
have less abortion you know and i think
that that's really important we need to
encourage motherhood encourage
parenthood encourage families and if we
did that then it doesn't matter what the
law said people wouldn't kill their
children i thought it was great actually
i don't know if you guys read vogue but
i was checking out vogue and uh
right
and uh rihanna is pregnant and her and
asap rocky are having a baby and i
thought it was really cool how she said
this was an unplanned pregnancy we
weren't trying to have kids and
immediately as soon as she got the
pregnancy test back they were like and
now we're on this journey and they went
for it they're not married yet they're
engaged and all of that but i really
thought that it was a very powerful
statement for this extremely popular pop
star to come out and say
i didn't intend to get pregnant and i'm
having my baby and i'm stoked about it i
love that but i i understand that but
you know rape is a specific rape is a
specific thing yeah it's and it's and
it's you can't you can't punish you
can't punish the child for the sins of
your father but you can't if you want if
you want to actually you can but the
mother is always punished for the sins
of the father that happens all right you
can't regardless of executing you want
so
so if you no rehabilitation for the guy
if a person is severely injured if a
person severely injures another person
and that and let's say they're rushing
to the hospital and there's two people
that are injured and they say
this guy's heart's failing hook them up
or this guy's kidneys failing we're
gonna we're gonna connect their
bloodstreams you wake up like hey i
didn't do this to this guy and they say
you can't separate because he'll die and
you're responsible but i have nothing to
do with this guy there are so many
differences between a abortion and that
that hypothetical it's like a famous
hypothetical judith jarvis thompson
first had that and um
so many differences like one is that
uh unplugging yourself from someone in a
hospital
is different from directly and
intentionally killing a baby like
abortion is not just simply unplugged
it's not you're just like unplugging you
you are killing the baby you are doing
something violent so it would be more
analogous to oh i don't want to be
hooked up to this guy so i'm going to
put a pillow over his face and kill him
and when you start framing it that way
all of a sudden it's it takes on a
different kind of feeling and also again
you're you are disregarding the
relationship so here's the real analogy
what if
your
your child
is in the hospital because of something
you did
and um and they need to be hooked up to
you for a short period of time in order
to survive well
i know but would it be acceptable
to because you don't want to be hooked
up to your child to put a pillow over
their face and just kill them of course
not right so so that's
we you can't ignore the relationship and
i don't know why it's it's a problem to
just say just like we say to parents of
born children no matter how the kid was
born we say you are responsible for that
child
you must take care of we are requiring
you by law to take care of the child or
you'll go to jail or find someone else
who will the issue of the issue is the
rape
that's that's the one thing that changes
all of this because i i absolutely say
if a person chooses to engage in these
behaviors they have accepted that
responsibility and they must adhere to
that responsibility but if a woman is
walking through a park on her you know
way home and uh it's you know 5 p.m and
someone grabs her and you know
drags her into a lobby or something or
into an alley and then she rushes to the
hospital and they do a check then a few
weeks later she finds out she's pregnant
and says i never chose this i resisted
they forced it upon me and i do not want
to provide my body to another person
then say we don't care you have to well
yeah and i think this is this is where
the argument gets stupid in our society
you know we see this amaze sex education
for children and i was reading through
some of their pdfs that was talking
about rape specifically that i thought
was fascinating because he was talking
about the need for consent and there was
a situation that was so outrageous that
would never happen and i noticed
something interesting it goes everyone
was there at a baseball game at phillip
and jackson's house and um you know
bethany had drank too much alcohol and i
thought wait a second we're about to
talk about sex and consent we're now
we're starting this underage drinking
okay so there's already the problem here
isn't isn't what i'm trying to say is
the problem here isn't the consent the
problem would be the underage drinking
we should work on because that's clearly
what's leading to the behavior when we
talk about the rape though with with
children the key thing is and that's
what i'm saying when we talk about rape
this is why they try to redefine even
what rape is in college where they say a
rape is if you regret it afterwards a
rape
but i'm being serious i'm genuinely
being serious the problem with the rape
argument is that you know you're going
okay if someone was forcibly i'm not
gonna get graphic but there's a violent
crime a violent crime that is heinous
against someone's bot a woman's body and
she's forcibly impregnated well number
one that's not the definition legally of
rape anymore and specifically socially
people just say rape can almost be like
gender it's if you just regretted it
later in life i know i'm genuinely
serious about it right i don't care
about the left's arguments on this well
that's it it does legally though i'm
saying so
for you not legally for all of you for
your morals and principles i'm just i
have no problem if your answer is the
woman must be forced my my attitude is
that freaks me out i'm not i'm not okay
with there's a there there's a
to answer your specific question so
uh we can all agree that if a woman is
impregnated through through violent like
forcible rape it's a horrible
unthinkable crime that was committed
against her which is why i think go
ahead and i'm all about executing
rapists um
if they're found guilty
but
you you still you have a person
a person was was created and they exist
now
and so the question is does that person
have moral worth do they have any human
rights at all
or or are we going to say that
the manner of your conception determines
whether you have moral worth and human
rights and i'm freaked out by that i i
don't agree with that yeah
real quick just to wrap uh i i i
understand too that
you know
in the instance a woman is raped she
will have the kid she will not die you
know in this circumstance you're saying
kill someone or a woman has a child for
you know is pregnant for nine months
you know i have a i have a lot of issues
with this scenario as well tim i have a
very similar perspective to yours um in
the event that you're raped
let's say by your father and you're 15
years old um are you then forced to have
that child are you forced to raise that
child you're forced to like you know
look at that child every day and see
that your father i don't agree with you
when you're 15 years old
that exists but that happened that's the
right thing that's the framing and are
you allowed to kill a child ever well i
i don't think that's entirely the
framing i don't care i think activities
i think
i think there's i think there's more to
it than that right i do think there's
more to it than that i think a big
problem with the abortion conversation
is how far it's it's gone to the point
where you have people you know in
arguing that you should be able to abort
for um
you know
illnesses that you should be able to
abort for deformities that you should be
able to abort for uh you know getting
the biological sex that you want all of
these things like having all of this
extra stuff in this conversation saying
like all of these various reasons that
you could abort your child that you
should be able to you know kill your
baby up to the point of delivery and all
of this
this has made this conversation so
insane that we completely forget um you
know
where it sort of started which was the
idea that it would be safe legal and
rare i'm not in favor of abortion it's
not something that i would do for myself
i don't know what i would do if i was
you know a teen who had been like raped
you know whatever else it is um
and i think that there's i think that it
it makes sense to discuss a woman's life
and what that life is going to be like
after she has been forcibly impregnated
by you know some horrible person i don't
think also the idea that once this woman
has been forcibly impregnated we're
going to kill the man who did it so that
now she can't even get child support
from this guy like he can't do anything
like that's insane too but how is it
doesn't seem right
no i i mean i'm 100 thoroughly opposed
to capital punishment in every single
circumstance i just want to make one
point before you jump in here i think
it's morally insane to say that if
somebody rapes a woman and she becomes
pregnant it's ethically permissible to
murder the child but not to put the
rapist to death
well isn't isn't it okay i'm not aware
of any reason to be pro-life other than
the two that i gave that
um the life in the womb is is a human
life
and it is never okay to intentionally
and directly kill innocent human life
that's my whole reason for being
pro-life i don't i can't think of any
other reason and so if that's your
reason for being pro-life then
you you can't make exceptions you can't
say well unless the babies conceive the
rabies it's more it's
incoherent i think that it makes sense
to talk to this woman this hypothetical
raped person that we're talking about it
makes sense to talk to them and to like
and you know encourage them to have a
child if
if they have you know the means and
whatever else and the mental capability
to do that um but i don't think it i
don't think that it should be the
federal government making that
determination there's an interesting
point here is as you know if we try to
create a value system on like moral
points what is what is more
morally weighted
then i think i understand a bit of the
conversation
it's that a woman will suffer a
physical constraint and large
inconvenience and
potentially trauma being forced to carry
this child but you'll live and the baby
won't so i understand that point it
there's a challenge in for me in the
idea of
just the extent to which society has
power over other people's bodies but i
totally see what you guys are saying 100
like the woman will not die by having a
baby and being pregnant for nine months
the baby will die and if we want to
maximize good
the challenge is does the state then say
you know you're going to sacrifice for
nine months and you know have this as
part of you for the rest of your life
but at least two people survive in the
long run it's
yeah tough questions man i think the
other thing is um sometimes what gets
mixed into this conversation is like
there's two questions about the the
the act itself and then kind of the
moral guilt
of
the person who participates in the act
and i certainly believe that your moral
guilt
participating in the act i'm talking
about abortion could be severely
mitigated if we're talking about a child
who's you know and is being taken
advantage of by the abortion industry as
well so that's sort of like a different
discussion about about um the woman and
her own moral guilt and and the levels
and and mitigating circumstances but but
they're still just the question of the
act itself and what it
this this
this this life that's being killed is it
a life that's the question and are you
directly killing it and is it ever okay
to directly kill into human life that's
that's the question one last question on
this before we go to the next story if
we develop a technology that can take a
uh you know fertilized ag even you know
day one
this is a question i always have as well
the point of viability if the point of
violet viability becomes uh day one day
you know minute one we can take it and
put it into some kind of machine or
technology that will allow it to live
would would would you uh would you guys
accept that
it is to a certain extent it's a very
huxley question right so the question
becomes then um
whose responsibility is this child are
we going to be
manufacturing parentless orphans in
order to choose the state wards of the
state is this what we're doing because
the state does
an amazing job right now raising orphans
right they do really just such stellar
work
um it's gorgeous you know we've seen the
results of this
uh of course it's spectacular
just a teeny weensy bit right um so
we've seen that so my question with with
this because this has been something
that i've considered as well
who raises the children
who
who gets to tell them what to do who
teaches them sex ed who teaches them
whether or not to you know castrate
themselves because they think they
should be something else and are we
going to create a class of citizens
that are responsible to the state that
the state is responsible for you know
what is this like this weird
stormtrooper thing we've got going well
you know for adoption maybe they can be
put up for adoption but who's who's
going to adopt this is just just real
quick
you guys thought on this if you know
women uh in any so let's let's take two
two forms of this question one is if a
woman gets pregnant through any
circumstance and then she says oh i'm
gonna place the baby into you know
proto-future
development and then the doctors
transplant it survives
would you be okay with that and the
second question is if a woman was forced
through rape and they said we're sorry
this happened to you but we can take the
baby out and help and it'll survive and
grow in this external process how would
you feel about that i want to mention
one thing in um when i last checked the
statistics in 2019 there were actually
twice as many couples on the waiting
list to adopt than there were abortions
that happened in the country that year
so i do think there would be people
willing to adopt but as for this this
theological i'm curious what what your
answer is here right i'll jump on but
it's i thought you're gonna give your
answer now you're saying yeah no no no i
want yours i want to see your question
um no no i mean i have an answer but i
just wanted to interject with that
before we got into it so the the
scenario is a woman is raped
child is conceived there's an option
though to remove the child and it will
grow into it and put the child into like
an artificial womb yeah
i mean if the other option is is killing
the child then i certainly would prefer
the artificial lume scenario let's say
the other option is just saying no
abortion you can't you have to have the
baby
should the woman be like no you can't
make me do this i never chose this
should we go with artificial womb or i
think there's a there's a complicated
well there's a complicated moral
question here for a few reasons i mean
firstly
would this be something that was 100
effective or would it pose a risk to the
life of the child and then if it is
my answer to my answer to this question
would be that there are um that's
fantastical this is okay yeah this is
this is a technology that it hasn't
developed there's nothing like it that
exists and so
my response here is that there are you
know gray-haired theologians with beards
much better and longer than mine who can
sort of stroke them all day and come up
with much better answers to this
question than i ever could i'm not sure
and that's who i would defer to if they
come
out i do think it's kind of an
interesting question because obviously
that we've talked recently even about
you know ivf uh and this idea people
keep talking about renting wombs even
that's surrogacy
yes yes but i mean more a slang has been
this uh room uh womb rental that has uh
kind of like plagued twitter where
people are arguing about this and not
just surrogacy but also like you know
talking about when it's just for
instance from a donor and also from the
original person and what are the ethics
of this and obviously well surrogacy is
prostitution except you get screwed for
nine months okay
well i was gonna say i mean i've met
some surrogates and it's been a very
interesting conversation especially when
you know meeting one one girl who uh was
a surrogate and the the baby had some
sort of a defect and the people who were
using the surrogate wanted her to abort
her he was a kid and she didn't want to
abort the kid and then when she gave
birth the baby's just taken from her and
she doesn't know what happened to the
child and i've had this story i've
spoken to her about it so it is an
interesting thing but this idea of
transhumanism is two things i don't
think it's going to happen like you
think where there's just a slab and
we're taking these rare rape victims
because i think we always use this very
niche argument of like could we create a
technology where if there's this rare
time even let's say a mom is dying from
cancer and the dad wants to keep the
baby and we could take the baby out and
grow the baby in this artificial womb
you know in many ways it sounds amazing
in ethical places in an ethical nation
but all i see right now is the movement
for that technology so that men can get
pregnant and that's what i've seen with
this trans this trans woman thing they
say trans women will give birth so i
don't see us moving towards an ethical
development of technology in this world
for the basis of trying to do what's
right i see us for trying to go outside
the design of humanity whether you're a
christian the design of god or you're
not a christian the biological
mechanisms that create a stable species
i don't think that we are developing
things for the right motives so i'd have
to say it's not even theological for me
i say no let's let's see i think the
story real quick the interesting thing
to me is i think we're just looking for
what the right answer is in every
circumstance right we're
looking for the kantian categorical
imperative i just real quick i
it is an interesting question but the
thing is
developing this technology where uh
hypothetically you could you could put a
child at the very early stages in into
like an artificial womb i think it's
it's good to
develop that kind of technology for the
the situation we're talking at the
beginning which is in a medical
emergency um to be able to be able to do
that but then you you realize that there
would be these abuses where now it's
kind of just a convenience thing let's
take the child out and put in the
artificial womb and that's that's a bad
thing and that's the thing about
technology is it would turn into that
instantly yeah women would be like well
why should i ruin my body for this when
we can put it in our voice well we saw
that right like kim kardashian had
babies via surrogate
nothing
okay i just want to say even even
intuitively when we look at this
potential technology this hypothetical
device
no one would argue that it would be
better for a child to develop in an
artificial womb rather than within the
body of their own mother so at the very
least there would need to be some kind
of justification the likes of which you
laid out these scenarios where your
child would have been delivering no idea
if it was death or artificial woman i
don't i don't know what the effect of ra
of of creating motherless orphans would
be i think that that is really something
that hasn't been explored
um to not know your mother in that sense
we have not seen a human being who
doesn't know their mother in that sense
and i think that we would end up with uh
something a little along the lines of a
sociopathic crazy person thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you